when you think of Pride and you think of
Pride monthly also just like the
statement of pride what does it mean to
you so important to celebrate pride you
know it's not always easy to come out
and steal that sense of pride especially
if you have sort of pressures around you
but you know we're a family and it's
okay to be who you are because love is
love and and you should feel pride and
power with that I want to talk a bit
about being two-spirit I want to do that
to explain to people that don't know
what it is and and its importance
there's a lot of misconception and I
feel very recently too about being
two-spirit a lot of people believe that
it's a new sort of term and identity
when in fact it represents an indigenous
person and that carries both the
understanding of the masculine and the
feminine walk of life and often they
were celebrated and they were healers
and visionaries and people that just
understood lights in a full kind of
scope because they carried both of those
spirit and in time for Pride Month
Shawnee has a brand new single don't go
[Music]
it's really just meant to be like a fun
love sort of upbeat song it kind of just
came - by accident it just sort of came
like naturally and it felt like like
just have fun and and pride is like an
excellent time in my opinion for it to
come out just to you know have fun and
feel that what light sort of vibe if no
wonder Shaunie feels like having fun
she's recently engaged to Olympian rugby
player Jen Kish who popped in during our
interview
congratulations on the engagement by the
way we got engaged during film it's a
surprise to me but we were just spending
so much time together and you know just
really getting to know each other and
Jen just come surprise me with the
question yeah cool it did us well yeah